[Music]
the movie neighbors let's talk about it
because you your co-star Zac Efron in
this film the guy I didn't know this but
apparently he's even ridiculous shape
it's insane
yeah it's freakish the the first time I
saw him with no shirt on my first
instinct was there was something wrong
with him honestly cuz he has so many
bumps sticking out of his body its body
like my body's like one big bump and his
is like 87 different little bumps that
come together to mate in the movie I
make a joke it's like his whole body's
like a giant arrow that points to his
dick kind of like someone like designed
the muscles like down from his gorgeous
face and then it like subtle he's like a
Plinko game with your eyes so man or a
woman there's no choice everyone it's
taking you down in the private jet bot
the price is right yeah it's crazy and
he would like he's without shirt in a
lot of the scenes in the movie and he
would like work out between takes which
was like psychotic to me because I'd be
like what are you doing man and he's
like oh it gives me energy and it makes
my muscles pop out more and all I would
say like is if I worked out between
takes I literally wouldn't be able to
act for like two hours until after I was
done and it was it was true that like we
had to keep writing into the scenes that
I like touched his body because like I
would just look at it and want to just
reach out and touch it as though it was
a mirage or some sort he's the sexiest
mother
he makes he brings it out of me I don't
like to apologize to Texas where my
friends behavior no but it's funny like
you you've been around when women have
encountered him yes what happens they
make a noise I've literally never heard
before you could give me three hours
with a woman I couldn't make her make
that noise that that they make I've been
with my wife ten years I haven't even
gotten one syllable of that sound that
women make because he's without a shirt
on in the movie again so like the whole
theater make guys make the noise you
hear it it's like a weird like uh like
it's so weird it's a noise I've
literally never heard before I think
it's coming from people's private parts
out their mouths
[Applause]